- All right. Hey everyone.
Welcome to this session.
We're gonna be talking today
about security best practices
for our serverless applications.
Just as a quick introduction,
my name is Heeki Park.
I am a Solutions Architect here at AWS.
I've been here about nine plus years.
I spent a lot of my time here
at AWS focusing on serverless,
and more lately spending a lot of time
with agentic applications.
- Thanks Heeki. My name's Chris McPeak.
I'm also a Solutions
Architect here at AWS.
Been here about seven and a half years,
really focused on serverless
application development
and working a lot with
our serverless teams.
So we're gonna be diving
into this topic today
around security best
practices for serverless apps.
Now, if you've never been
in a silent session before,
these can get a little bit weird, right?
It's hard for you to hear
me through headphones
versus over a speaker.
We like to get feedback, so head nods
and you know, thumbs up
if something's resonating.
Definitely appreciate.
But I wanna do something a
little bit different this morning
or this afternoon.
On the count of three,
I would love everybody just to cheer.
That helps me.
That also tells everybody
else you all chose
the right session, okay. Ready?
So we're gonna do this together. Ready?
One, two, three.
(participants cheering)
Thank you. Awesome.
Okay, so as we dive into this,
I'm gonna start off and go
into a little bit of a survey
of some different security practices
for serverless applications,
some foundation items
that we need to really kind of
talk through to get started.
And then I'm gonna have
Heeki come back up,
and he's gonna dive deeper
into some specific use cases,
especially around some of
the more modern application
development that we've been working on,
especially with agentic AI,
and some of the identity awareness
that we need to think about
with serverless security.
Now to help us out, what we're gonna do
is kind of frame this in the
idea of a fitness tracker
'cause I think sometimes
it's a little bit hard
to get our head around security
without having an actual
application to talk through,
or an architecture to talk through.
So we're gonna use this idea
of having a fitness tracker.
And the basic architecture
that we're gonna work with
is we're gonna have our athlete.
I love cycling.
I've done a lot of cycling in the past,
as you can tell though,
I haven't been cycling a lot recently.
So instead we're gonna use Heeki.
Heeki is training for
a marathon right now.
Actually ran a marathon last week,
and loves using fitness trackers,
and collecting all of
his data and figuring out
how he's doing with running.
So we're gonna have
this basic architecture.
So an API that's gonna collect
that data from our tracker,
that's gonna feed into an API gateway.
From that API gateway will
trigger a lambda function.
That's just gonna take that data
and write it to a DynamoDB table.
So as we go through and
talk about security,
we'll be talking about
some of the security
that you need to consider on
each of the different layers
of this application.
Okay, so the first thing that
we need to talk about actually
is account boundaries.
Now, I realize this isn't
necessarily a serverless concept,
but it is something important to consider
as we're developing applications.
How many of you in the audience
are developers? Awesome.
How many are security engineers
or focused on compliance?
Great. So as developers,
we love to move fast.
We love to build very quickly.
Oftentimes we'll have access
to a sandbox environment
where we can develop quickly,
run our tests and move fast.
But this can pose some risks
to a production environment
when we're deploying
directly into that account.
So by creating these account boundaries,
that actually allows us
then to separate those areas
of control so that you as
a developer can move fast,
and test and develop.
And then as you're
deploying out to production,
then you can have a
structured deployment pipeline
where as a developer,
you can commit your code
and it will run those automated tests
and deploy that out to production for you.
So that's a really important
sort of distinction
between accounts that just helps provide
a good separation of concerns.
Encryption, we all love
to talk about encryption
and it's very important
for us to consider.
With AWS serverless services,
a lot of security is
already built in for you,
but there are some things to consider
as you're using some of
the different services.
So for example, if you're
using Lambda functions,
one thing that you'll want to think about
is your environment variables
and whether or not you're storing data
in environment variables
that needs to be encrypted.
And you can use a KMS key
to actually encrypt those
environment variables
and keep them safe.
If you're using API gateway
and using a caching feature
with API gateway, again,
you wanna make sure
that, that cache is actually encrypted.
And API gateway gives you
the ability to turn that on.
So for each of the different
serverless services,
those are available.
Some have the option to
use just an AWS KMS key,
and in some cases you can also
use a customer managed key
to encrypt that as well.
Now all of the serverless
services do have encryption
in transit by default.
So we manage that for you.
API gateway only accepts HTPS requests,
so you can't even accidentally
create an HTTP endpoint
that doesn't run
encryption on API gateway.
Okay, the next area that we
need to think through is IAM,
so identity and access
management, very important.
As you're building
serverless applications,
that control plane where
you're making API calls to AWS
to make changes to Lambda functions
or access different services
is one plane to think about
making sure it is secure.
And the other is the data plane.
So this is where your application
is calling different services,
and your application is running.
And so there are a couple
of different tools in IAM
that we'll go through to consider
as you're building out your applications.
The first is at an organization level,
and I'll dive into this a
little bit deeper in a moment.
AWS organizations policies
or SEPs are gonna be scoped
at an organization level
that can be applied
across multiple accounts,
versus resource policies
are going to be policies
that you're gonna apply
to a specific service.
And so that will control access
to that specific service.
So as you start digging into IAM policies
at different layers,
there are different areas
that you can protect.
So when we think about our architecture
for our activity API, controlling
what APIs are being called
and how API gateway is
invoking our Lambda function,
we'll wanna make sure that we bound
those permissions very closely.
Okay, so with Lambda
functions specifically,
I wanna talk a little bit
about resource based policies
versus the execution role of that service.
So this is a little bit different
than how you might consider security
for maybe an application
running on an EC2 instance.
So with Lambda functions, you
have two different policies
that you're gonna work with.
That resource-based policy
is what gets applied
for any service that's triggering,
or invoking your Lambda function.
There's a couple of other services
that also follow this
pattern such as EventBridge,
and so you'll wanna make
sure that you think through
that resource-based policy
for what services can
invoke that Lambda function.
Now, the execution role
is on the other side
of the Lambda function.
That's the policy that's controlling
what that Lambda function has
access to as it's executing.
So maybe it's a DynamoDB table,
as we mentioned before
in our architecture.
So that gives you a
different policy to control
what that Lambda function is accessing.
So for example, based on our application
that we're working with,
maybe that API gateway,
we wanna give it access to
invoke our Lambda function
as those activities are coming
in and need to be processed.
So we'll create a resource-based
policy to do that,
but we'll also give it that execution role
so the Lambda function
can write those activities
out to DynamoDB.
Okay, another concept
that's really important
that maybe as developers
we don't always think about
but is a really foundational ideas
is around least privileges.
Now, I don't know about you all,
but this was a little bit hard
for me to get my head around
as a developer because
I like to move fast,
I like to try things and
sometimes it's just easy
to scope something very wide open.
But for those that are
security folks in the room,
I can already see the cringing, right.
With having wide open policies.
So least privilege is very important
as you're developing in the
cloud, you wanna make sure
that you're scoping those
policies down to only the actions
that, that service is allowed to take.
So if you think about
your resource policies
or your execution policies,
you want to not give it a wild card star,
but instead give it only the API actions
that it's allowed to take.
Now we can think about this
in a little bit of an iterative way
as we're developing as well,
where we're setting
permissions, running tests,
verifying actions, and we can
all do this in our pipelines
as well to verify that we
have permissions set well
to meet the compliance
for our organization.
Now, the other side of
that is, as a developer,
you know, I might wanna set the policies
for my services wide open, right?
We already talked about
least privilege there.
Least privilege also matters
for me as a developer.
So making sure that I don't have access
to things I shouldn't
or I can't take actions
that might cause problems down the road,
or open up issues down the road.
And so one way that you can handle this
is by actually empowering your developers
to create the policies they need,
but also use permission boundaries
applied to that developer
that actually limits the scope
of what they can open up.
And so you can actually set
specific actions to deny,
or allow on those permission boundaries.
Sorry, no allow, just deny
so that you're limiting
what a developer actually
can do in their account.
Now this is gonna be
a little bit different
than the SEP roles, SEP policies
that I mentioned before,
where SEPs are organizational wide,
a permission boundary
is gonna be just scoped
for that role specifically.
So let's take a little
bit of an example here.
So for our activities, API
that I talked about before,
maybe I want, you know, full
access to all the Lambda APIs,
full access to Dynamo and API gateway,
I set a policy for any get actions,
so I can see what my API gateway is,
but my security team
really doesn't like that.
They want me to scope that
down a little bit further.
They can actually put in a
permission boundary in place
that only gives me access
to Lambda Invoke function
and DynamoDB UpdateItem,
and apigateway Get method.
So you can see effectively
when I bring these two
permission boundaries
and the policy that I
put in place together,
the actual effective permissions
is just Lambda Invoke Function
and DynamoDB update table.
So even though I've given myself
some wild card permissions
to move fast, using that
permission boundary actually scoops
what I have access to down very tightly.
Okay, so let's go back to SCP again,
and talk about this a little bit more.
Usually when you get to an
enterprise level organization
that's doing a lot of serverless
application development,
a lot of times we don't want
to have to apply specific
controls at every single role.
Maybe there are some
policies for compliance
that we wanna apply
across our organization,
across all of the accounts
that we actually have.
And so using SCPs, you can
actually apply these policies
across the entire organization.
So this just limits the scope
that any of those policies
might have access to.
Now to help, let's talk
through maybe an example
of something that could be helpful.
In our case, we have that API
gateway sitting out front.
And maybe what we wanna do
is we wanna limit access
to that API gateway from the public side.
We don't wanna create
a public API endpoint.
So what we can do
is we can actually just allow
private endpoints using SCP.
So as any of our developers
create an API gateway,
they can only create it
as a private endpoint,
not a public endpoint.
Now, maybe to make this
a little bit more real,
let's talk a little bit
about a different scenario.
So in this case, we want
any of the traffic coming
from those trackers to actually
flow through a different VPC
because in this case maybe we wanna run
some security validation,
or we want to route
traffic a certain direction
within our AWS network.
And so what we can do is lock
down that public API access,
so that we can then just
create a private API endpoint
and stick it in its own VPC.
Then as traffic is coming in,
it's gonna flow through that broader VPC,
maybe we do some, again,
some security analysis
on that traffic.
We'll create ENIs in
that account, in that VPC
that then allow traffic to
flow into our API gateway VPC
on the back end.
So that just provides a
little bit more security
for our API endpoints if we have a need
to actually flow traffic through VPCs.
Okay, last sort of
foundational area to remember,
think about API integrations.
So I'm not gonna talk too
much about API Integrations
because Heeki's gonna
talk through some of that
in a few minutes.
But databases is also an important area.
Now in our case, DynamoDB table,
and DynamoDB supports
IAM so I can give access
to that Lambda function
using an IAM policy
to access that DynamoDB table.
But what if my database doesn't
necessarily support IAM?
Maybe it's a database
that I'm just running
maybe on an EC2 instance.
So in that case,
you might think about using
something like Managed Secrets,
but the last thing you want
to do is take those secrets
and actually apply them in...
Hard code them in your code, right?
So that's where Secrets
Manager is a good place
to store those and have your
Lambda function actually access
that Secrets manager to be
able to access your database.
Okay, a couple of other
areas just to think about
as an organization,
if we think about the
development lifecycle
and all the different stages that we have
in the development lifecycle,
there's a number of
different security things
to just keep in mind, whether
it's how you're authoring
your applications and where
you're storing that code,
making sure you have least
privileged permissions there,
or even pushing code into repositories
to trigger your pipelines.
Making sure you have IAM scoped down,
so that your pipelines
are only deploying code
from the right people.
Another area that's really
important to think about
is just analyzing that source code,
looking for maybe
dependencies that have come in
that were applied that
maybe have issues in them.
Amazon Inspector is a good way to do that,
to have Amazon Inspector look at your code
and provide any of those dependency issues
that maybe have crept in.
But I will say if (indistinct)
Matt Garmin's keynote
this morning, he actually
(indistinct) agent,
we didn't know that,
that was available then.
Did everybody (indistinct) still?
- [Participant] Mic is
cutting out sometimes.
- My mic is cutting out sometimes.
Okay, we'll have our
folks in the background.
I'll keep talking and they'll check on it.
Okay, so Matt Garmin this morning talked
about a security agent
that we recently released.
This is also a really
good tool to make use of
to analyze your source code.
Okay, so another type
of possible scenario is,
let's say you weren't inspecting your code
and you allowed a dependency
to be applied in your application
that got through some of your testing.
So in this case, you might want to look
for application anomalies to detect
that maybe that dependency got through.
And so at a runtime, Amazon GuardDuty
can look at your VPC flow logs as a way
to detect any anomalies
that are maybe happening
in your application because
something was missed earlier on.
Okay, event payloads.
Another important area to consider
as you're thinking about security.
So with event payloads in Lambda,
there's actually a really
good tool out there
called Power Tools that
makes it really easy for you
to add things like strict
typing to validate that input
as it's coming through.
So you can see here this
is just a brief example
where we're importing that
Power Tools dependency
and that's gonna actually help us
to validate very easily in Lambda.
There's some really good
power tools sessions going on
this week that's...
There's a team at AWS now
that's actually developing that
and owns that for us.
So I definitely encourage
you to take a look at that.
But what if we could also
look at those payloads
before they come to Lambda,
and look for maybe differences in schema
before a request actually comes in.
And so within API gateway,
we can validate that input,
do input validation,
make sure we're getting what we expect
to get from a schema
perspective before we pass it on
to that Lambda function to actually run.
So three available configurations.
So you can look at the body,
you can look at query string parameters,
make sure they're what you expect,
or you can look at all the
above to validate that event
that's coming through.
Okay, last couple sort
of foundational items,
protecting your API endpoints.
So before we talked a little bit
about taking our endpoints
and making them private.
Another tool that you
have access to is AWS WAF.
This gives you the ability
to protect those endpoints
based on IP addresses, based on, you know,
geographic regions that you
might want to limit access
to that API gateway.
AWS WAF also has the
ability to take in rule sets
from third parties.
So this is a really
helpful way to, you know,
have a subscription applied
that will actually protect those endpoints
based on what's being
seen out in the wild.
If you go on the AWS marketplace,
there's a number of providers
that will provide that
subscription for you into AWS WAF.
So those are some really good ways
of protecting your endpoints
using an outside tool like WAF.
But now I'm gonna hand it over to Heeki
who's gonna dive into some
identity aware applications.
- Cool, thank you Chris.
Can you guys hear me?
All right, sweet.
So Chris gave us a really
good broad spectrum
of a lot of different things
that we need to be thinking about
as we are building our
serverless applications.
What I'm gonna do is over the
next maybe 15, 20 minutes,
we're gonna actually dive really deep
on one particular kind
of application stack
security consideration, which I'm seeing
as a very common use case,
especially as we start to think
about both serverless applications,
but also agentic applications,
which is a common thing
that I see a lot of my customers
starting to think about.
So we're gonna go back to the application
that Chris presented before,
again, we have our
fitness web application.
So this is the first component
that the user is gonna
be interacting with.
Of course, that web application
is gonna then interact
with our serverless API gateway,
this is gonna be the activities, routes,
et cetera, those APIs.
And then of course the
business logic will reside
within our Lambda function.
So a bunch of what Chris
talked about already
is going to be these resource
policies, execution roles,
perhaps even those SEPs
for doing deployments.
The part that I'm gonna
spend a bunch of my time on
is going to actually be
here on the left side,
thinking about user
authentication, authorization.
How do we make sure that the user,
so let's say Heeki is interacting
with this fitness application,
is doing things that he is allowed to do
and is accessing resources that
I'm allowed to access, okay.
So before we get into that,
let's take a quick look at
our serverless application.
So this is the one that
Chris had introduced before.
And again, we have these
different API endpoints
that he had introduced before.
The thing to notice that,
again Chris had talked about
was we have a number of different
of these APIs that again,
you can think about as
the architects in the room
we're using like domain driven design,
and these are some bounded contexts.
These are the domains of logic.
So you can imagine different teams
are provisioning these different APIs,
and maybe they have different off schemes
and we're gonna get into that momentarily.
The key thing that a lot
of organizations will do
when they're protecting
these type of API endpoints
is going to be using a
standard called OAuth2.
And we're gonna dive
pretty deep into OAuth2.
But before we do, why don't we go over
a couple of the terminology
that we're gonna be using
throughout the rest of this talk.
So when we think about OAuth2,
there are a number of different entities
that we want to be aware of.
So the first is the
owner of that resource.
So you could imagine maybe
there's some amount of data
we are trying to protect
and let's say Heeki again,
maybe I'm a Strava user,
I really like to run,
so I have some of my data in this service
and I own...
In theory, I own the data,
or I should be the one that
grants access to that data.
I then use maybe a web
browser, maybe a mobile client.
In this example, we'll
just use a web browser
that is going to be the user agent.
So that is the mechanism by
which I'm gonna be interacting
with these protected resources.
Then you have the web application.
So my web browser of course connects
to a particular web application.
Maybe I have it deployed in Fargate.
That web application or client
then interacts with the API
that we are trying to protect.
So this is that serverless API
that Chris was talking about before.
And last but not least,
of course there is the
authorization server, right?
So we need some entity,
some identity provider
to be able to determine who is allowed
to access these resources,
and what resources are they
allowed to access, okay.
So these are the five key kind of entities
that we're gonna be thinking about
throughout this entire flow.
Another thing that we wanna think through
is how do we actually get
access to the resources?
So there's some process
by which this access
is going to be granted.
So there are actually a number of 'em,
in this talk we're just
gonna talk about two.
Really, we're gonna talk about one
and then we'll see how
when you learn about one,
you've already learned
about the second one.
So the first one is authorization code,
or code authorization flow.
And this is the most common one
that probably you're familiar with.
So you may be familiar with
like when you click on a webpage
and it says, do you wanna allow access
to this particular application
for these resources?
That is an example of
code authorization flow.
The second one is client credentials flow.
So where the first one is end user facing,
so I'm logging into a webpage
and then I'm gonna allow access,
client credentials is typically used
in machine to machine communication.
In the former, you have this
user interactive experience
where someone is gonna be
clicking, essentially allow.
In a client credential scenario,
you want a machine to be able to do that.
So there is no user that's
gonna be clicking that approve
or allow button.
Okay, so these are two flows
we're gonna talk about.
We're gonna dive really
deep in code authorization
and then you'll see how
you've already learned
about client credentials.
Some other things that
we wanna think about.
So the relevant credentials
that you wanna be aware of.
So when you are creating an application,
or maybe when a developer,
you as a developer are
building an application,
you actually need to
register that application
with your identity provider.
So the first thing that
you end up creating
is what we call the client ID.
And perhaps the simplest
way to think about it,
it's not exactly like this,
but you can almost think
of this like a username.
So me as an entity
interacting within the system,
maybe Heeki has a username
that is associated with me.
Well, for an application,
you would have a client ID
associated with that application.
So when you register it
with the identity provider,
it will vend you a client ID.
Next then is the client secret.
And again, as you can imagine,
this is somewhat similar
to having a password,
so a username password,
but this would be
essentially the client ID
and client secret for the
particular application.
And these two together are used
to then essentially authenticate
that this is the application interacting
with the identity provider, okay?
All right, one more set of tokens,
and then we're gonna kind
of dive pretty deep into it.
And then we're gonna apply this
to our serverless application, right?
So these are a number of
different tokens that you then get
when you exchange your
client ID and client secret,
and my user identity, right?
So the first is an ID token.
This is a short lived token.
The really simple way to think about this
is this ID token identifies
who is interacting
with this service.
So it might have information
like my username,
maybe my email.
Again, this is all dependent
on what you want to include
in your application.
The next is the access token,
and this is perhaps the
one that is most important.
This is the one that defines,
you've authenticated,
now this defines what are the actions
that you are allowed to take.
So we call these scopes.
This will say, I'm allowed
to, you know, have read access
to this particular endpoint.
Maybe I have write access
And then last but not least
is what we call the refresh token.
So you can imagine in the
code authorization flow
as a user interacting with
it, it might be painful
to every 15 minutes or every 60 minutes
to ask that user to
re-approve that request.
While the refresh token is then used
to actually do that automatically.
So you may...
This might be a longer lived credential,
maybe we're gonna allow this
credential to live for 24 hours
and we'll refresh the user's tokens
by using this refresh token, okay.
So these are the credentials tokens,
and some of the identities within it.
So these are all the components necessary
when you're building
serverless applications
or as we show in a little bit,
we're going to see how
this is gonna be used
for your agentic applications as well.
(participants clapping)
Thank you. Thank you.
Alright, so the first phase,
I'm gonna talk about two phases.
So for the code authorization flow,
there's really two phases
and in this first phase really
what you wanna think about it
is the user is essentially logging in
and getting an authorization code, right?
And so you have this user, so Heeki,
I'm gonna log into the web browser.
You can imagine I'm gonna get redirected
to a login page, right?
And so again, this is probably
familiar with all of you.
After I log in, then
you get that little...
That popup that says, do
you wanna allow Heeki access
to this particular resource?
And it'll have a bunch of check boxes.
We're gonna go ahead and approve.
Once you hit approve,
things on the backend
is the identity provider
will generate an off code.
And so this is just
basically a long string,
it's a one-time use string.
It then sends that back to the front end.
So the front end application
receives this off code.
It already had the client
ID and client secret,
so again, this is something
that you registered
with your identity provider
when you created the application.
When you now deploy the application,
that gets deployed alongside
with the application.
So now the application
has the client's ID,
client secret that it uses to authenticate
with the identity provider.
It now has the off code,
which is now user specific
and it uses that to then
exchange for a set of tokens.
So this is the first phase
that is user interactive.
Now the second phase is, okay,
so we had this front end application,
it was deployed with
that client ID in secret,
it just received that off code,
that exchange that we just did,
it is now gonna go to
my authorization server.
In this case I'm gonna use Amazon Cognito
and it sends the client ID,
the client secret and that off code.
And Cognito will then
validate these strings
and credentials, it will then provide back
the ID token, access
token, and refresh token
to the front end application.
The one thing that I wanna stress here
is as you're building your
serverless applications,
you are not going to
expose these ID tokens,
access tokens and refresh
tokens to the web browser.
You wanna make sure these
stay within the bounds
of the front end application.
These are not things
that your end users should
actually end up seeing.
This is all happening in the backend.
So what happens is you'll
send, let's say the ID token
with API gateway, that
goes to the authorizer.
API gateway will then take that ID token,
go back to the authorization server,
and go and validate is
this a valid ID token?
So again, it'll go in and say, okay,
I see this is an ID token from Heeki.
He wants to then go and access, you know,
the backend API.
API gateway once it
receives that validation,
it sees, okay, this is an
allowed request, it will then...
Oops, I guess I didn't have it in there.
It will then allow it to, let's say,
invoke the Lambda function on the backend.
And as Chris had talked about before,
this assumes then you
had already configured,
let's say a resource-based
policy with your Lambda function
so that API gateway is
allowed to actually invoke it.
Okay, so we talked about phase one
is with that the end user interaction.
Phase two is on the backend
where you have the, again,
the client application,
the front end application
doing a bunch of these token exchanges.
The reason we break this up into...
Actually I think I'm skipping ahead here.
So this is actually a quick
a refresh of the whole flow.
So user comes in, connects
to the front end application,
logs in, gets the off code,
sends it back to the
front end application.
It then validates that, invokes the API,
the API gateway will check
with the authorization server.
And then here's where we
have that Lambda function
that then gets invoked
with that resource server.
So what's nice here then is within Lambda,
again, for those folks that have built
with Lambda functions,
how many of you guys have deployed
a production application using Lambda?
Okay, a lot of you folks,
so you know with your Lambda
functions, with your handler,
you have two parameters there.
One is your event payload,
and then one is your context payload.
So you can actually see
within the context payload
a bunch of identity information.
So this could be something
where maybe as a developer you know
that this was an authorized request,
but maybe there's some additional things
that you may want to do
within your business logic.
Maybe you have like a grouping of users,
and based on certain
entitlements you wanna allow them
to do certain custom actions.
This is something you
could then custom code
into your Lambda functions.
So this is a lot of additional information
you have available to you
even after you've already done
the OAuth flow.
So what I was getting at before
is we talked about phase one
and phase two.
Phase one is the user interaction,
phase two is that machine to machine.
Well, with client credential
flow you can essentially strip
off phase one, that login piece
and the exchange for that off token.
And now for client credentials
it's just phase two.
So you've now basically learned both.
So here you see that web application,
it gets deployed with the
client ID and client secret.
Now it just exchanges the client ID,
and client secret for that set of tokens,
that ID access and refresh token.
In this scenario we no
longer need the off code
because this is not interacting
with any particular user.
So again now we just do that same flow.
We send maybe that barer
token along to API gateway,
it then goes and validates
with your identity provider
and then invokes your Lambda function.
So you're kind of asking like, okay,
that was a lot to try
to understand OAuth2,
well with a lot of both serverless APIs
and also with a lot of
agentic applications,
OAuth2 is the foundation
security mechanism for ensuring
that users have access
to the appropriate downstream resources.
So for folks that are
building serverless APIs,
or if you're thinking
about even building agentic applications,
this is going to be a core flow
that you're gonna wanna understand.
And we're gonna talk about
how we make this a
little bit easier for you
in the next couple slides.
So we covered OAuth, but what
about, are there other ways
for your serverless APIs
to think about doing
the same type of mechanisms
for fine grain permissions?
Well there is.
So you can also do something
with Amazon Verified Permissions.
So similar flow, you have
an end user coming in,
they're gonna authenticate
with the identity provider.
You will then try to access...
So I cut out the client,
'cause you can just
assume it goes through.
You're gonna then try to access
your API gateway endpoint.
And here you're gonna include that token
as a bar token within the header.
And in this case with API gateway,
you can actually use
now a Lambda Authorizer.
So you can configure an
authorizer to then interact
with our verified
permission service, right?
And so you can actually take the header,
whatever that token might be,
and then it will then go
and do a verification.
So here's the token that comes in,
run it against Amazon
Verified Permissions.
Amazon Verified Permissions
will then come back
and say allow or deny.
And then based on that,
we'll then perhaps invoke
the backend if that was allowed.
Now you may be asking like how do we know,
or how do we actually define
like who's allowed to do what?
Great question. So with
Verified Permissions,
what it actually does is it
actually uses a policy language
on the backend.
And this is actually an open source
policy language called Cedar.
Here's a little bit of
what that might look like.
So this is an example.
So maybe for the security folks,
I saw when Chris was asking
before there was maybe a third
or maybe even a half of this audience,
you're really focused on
the security side of things.
You can actually using code
define the allowed actions
for a particular set of resources.
So here's an example
where perhaps we have
a particular namespace.
So I want to include, so here at reInvent
we have a bunch of APIs that are defined
for demos here at reInvent.
There's actually also a group of users.
So maybe the audience here
in this particular session
is going to be included as
part of this permission.
And then this is then
the Cognito user pool.
Along with the Cognito user group, right?
So this is the principle,
this is the allowed identity
that is gonna be defined
by this particular policy.
And then this then is the allowed action.
So the audience here, if
you were to make a request
to my particular API that
uses this Lambda authorizer,
we'll be allowed to make a get request
to the /products API endpoints,
or maybe the /activities API endpoint.
So this is an example of a
policy I can define using Cedar,
I would then essentially
configure Verified Permissions
to then use this policy when API gateway
makes these type of requests.
Okay, so a number of different ways.
We talked about OAuth in depth,
we talked about using Verified Permissions
to be able to identify
users that are coming in,
make sure we have these
identity aware interactions
with my serverless APIs.
So let's try to push the
boundaries a little bit,
and think about is there a way
we can continue to innovate
from a security perspective
in where we're seeing a lot of
new applications being built.
So coming back to our
Serverless Fitness Application,
we have our traditional application,
we have again our different API endpoints.
So one thing that we
may wanna think about,
and you may have heard
about some of this again,
even in the keynote this
morning, Matt Garmin was talking
a little bit about using
and building agents.
And so one way we can think
about maybe transitioning
our serverless fitness application
into an agent application
is using something called
tool calling, right?
So within our agents now
we're gonna build this agent
using an agentic framework.
We have an ability to then create
and define what we call tools.
The simplest way to think
about this is, is a tool
is just another function that
we're gonna annotate as a tool
and we're gonna then call our
different serverless APIs.
So the activities route
socials, and support API
that we already have for our
serverless fitness application.
We're just gonna essentially
wrap it in a function,
and annotate it as a tool.
The nice thing then here...
So these are the tools that
we're gonna be able to create.
The nice thing then here
is that our agentic application here,
as it interacts with a model, an LLM,
it is able to very easily
gain access to the data
that is accessible from
these different APIs.
So you can imagine
maybe Heeki as a runner,
I just did, let's say for the
last 30 days I did 10 runs
over that period of time,
and I actually wanna do
a little bit of analysis.
I wanna try to understand, you know,
what is my average heart
rate over this period of time
for a particular weather condition,
and am I actually improving in my fitness
or am I actually getting worse?
Is there something that
I need to change in that?
So this is certainly something
that in a serverless
application I can go and build,
and write imperative code
to be able to do this.
But maybe as a developer,
maybe there's a simpler way to do this
and maybe I can actually
leverage an agent application
to be able to do that on my behalf.
And this is perhaps where
some of the ideation can come,
and why we may wanna actually
move into this direction.
Okay, so thinking about tool calling,
then you may be thinking,
okay, do I have to like wrap
a lot of my APIs and do a bunch of work
in order to be able to bring this data,
bring this API data into my agent?
Well, fortunately we've actually created
or we didn't create,
Anthropic created an open
specification last year,
and you may have heard of it,
anyone ever heard of the
acronym M-C-P? M-C-P.
So a number of handfuls.
So MCP stands for model context protocol.
It is basically a specification
that standardizes the way
that you do tool calling
within an agentic application, right?
So this is where you can
now as your fitness agent
can essentially have
a singular MCP client,
and now the different data
providers can then provide
an MCP server, right?
And so again, you can
imagine with the activities,
routes, socials and support APIs,
maybe those are actually by
different development teams
within your organization.
So you can imagine team A
is doing the activities API,
team B is doing the routes API, et cetera.
So each of those teams as data providers,
or as API providers would be responsible
for vending an MCP server.
Now you may be asking, okay,
what does this all have to do
with the security talk that
we're really focused on here?
Well, in this whole process there are...
Continue to be security considerations.
So here's an example where
all of that OAuth2 stuff
that we just talked about and learned,
we're gonna apply that into
this agentic application.
So you could imagine
as an end user interacting with an agent,
maybe there's the code
authorization flow, right?
And so again, as an end user,
maybe I'm accessing this
through a web browser,
I'm gonna log in and then
I'm gonna click authorize
and now I have access
to this fitness agent.
You can imagine then I asked that question
that I asked before of
like help me understand
the last 30 days of running.
Can you do an analysis on my data?
Am I improving and do I need
to change something in the way
that I'm training?
The fitness agent will then
make a determination and say,
actually make a call
to our activities tool,
which will use the MCP clients
and talk to the MCP server.
So again, because this is a machine
to machine communication,
maybe we've configured client
credentials to allow my agent
to be able to talk to this MCP server,
but that's actually not the last step.
The MCP server itself
is going to then talk to
my serverless API, right?
And so maybe we have a setup here
where we're gonna also
use client credentials
because this is also a machine
to machine communication.
You may also want to think,
actually I want to make sure
I'm propagating identity
information from Heeki
as the end user accessing
the agent all the way down
to the activities API.
So maybe instead of a client credentials,
maybe we actually want to use
the code authorization flow.
And for the astute in the audience,
you're probably thinking
how do you do that?
My MCP server and activities
API is way far in the back end.
How do I actually propagate
that end user request?
Well there is a way
you can actually stream
that request back all
the way to the front end,
so that I as a user can
actually hit the accept button.
Okay, so we talked a
little bit about, you know,
we have our serverless
fitness application.
We're thinking maybe
this is an opportunity
to build an agentic application.
We spent a bunch of
time on the OAuth2 flow.
We talked about Amazon
Verified Permissions.
This is a lot of security stuff
that we wanna think through.
Is there perhaps a simpler
way that we can do this?
There is a simpler way,
or perhaps an alternate way to do this.
So again, in the keynote earlier today,
there was a bunch of
announcements around AgentCore.
So there are a couple of services
to actually make this simpler.
So AgentCore runtime
is a serverless runtime
similar to Lambda, similar even to Fargate
to be able to run your agent applications.
On top of that is then something
called AgentCore Gateway,
similar to API gateway where
API gateway is the front door
for all of your API front ends.
We think of AgentCore
gateway as a front end
for all of your tools that
you're gonna then expose
to your agent applications.
There are a number of managed tools
that you have available to you.
So again, browser, if you
want your agents to be able
to go and do research on the internet,
maybe you want to hit
other websites to be able
to glean information
about the particular query
that the user is coming in,
you could use AgentCore browser.
Code interpreter is a situation
where maybe your agent
is actually gonna be
generating code on your behalf
and this is untrusted code.
You don't want to actually
run this within the context
of your...
Perhaps your enterprise,
you want this code to
be actually be isolated.
And this is where you might
actually use something
like AgentCore code interpreter.
Where we'll spend a little bit of time
in the next slide is AgentCore identity
where we think about all of
these OAuth considerations,
all of these security
considerations in this auth flow.
And is there a way that we
could actually make it simpler?
AgentCore identity aims to
make that process simpler.
And we're going to dive
into the next slide.
There's also AgentCore memory.
So in your experiences with
different agent applications,
one of the key experience benefits
that we've seen customers
wanting out of these applications
is this personalized experience.
So this desire to see,
hey, it actually remembers
that this is Heeki interacting
with this fitness application
and remembering even
some of the last queries
about the particular application.
So memory will allow
you to do some of that.
And then of course there's observability.
So observability will allow
you to understand the full flow
of the actions that are happening
within this particular application.
It will also give you an idea
of the type of login
activities and the tool calls
that are being made with this application.
But again, let's talk a little
bit more about identity,
and how we can actually
apply some of the OAuth flows
in this agentic application
in a simpler way.
So before we talked again
about maybe there's the user,
maybe there's the interacting
through the web browser,
and now we wanna actually interact
with this particular agent.
So on the front end side there's something
what we call inbound auth.
And the idea here is if
this is a application
perhaps running on an EC2 instance,
maybe it's actually being
invoked by a Lambda function,
we could probably use
something like IAM, so IAM,
you can then do all of the things
that Chris was talking about before.
So IAM basically defines
what are the actions
that this entity within
AWS is allowed to do.
So if there's an app
running in EC2, in Fargate,
or even in Lambda, that execution role
would allow us to invoke
this particular agent.
Alternatively, if it's
actually maybe external
to your organization, this is
not actually running in AWS,
this is running in your own infrastructure
and you don't have an IAM role associated
with that particular infrastructure,
you're likely gonna then use OAuth2,
which we went to in great depth.
Then we have what we call outbound auth.
And outbound auth is basically configured
based on whatever the
target might actually be.
So if your agent is going to be accessing,
let's say an S3 bucket, so if
your agent is gonna try and go
and extract additional
information out of PDF documents
in an S3 bucket, you'll just
use an IAM role for that.
So similar to what Chris
was talking about before,
depending on what you're
gonna be accessing
is what you're gonna
actually end up using.
So again, maybe an S3
bucket, maybe a Dynamo table,
maybe something else
within your AWS account,
this is where you'll use an IAM
role for your outbound auth.
Otherwise, for anything else,
you're gonna end up using OAuth2.
And this is why we spend a
bunch of time on that OAuth flow
to really help you understand
when are you gonna be using
those different flows.
So if you have an end user interacting
with a particular protected
endpoint, that's likely
where you're gonna be using
the code authorization flow.
And then if this is machine
to machine communication,
you're likely gonna be using something
like the client credentials flow.
Okay, so why don't we have a
couple, I guess, key takeaways
from this talk.
So the first thing that...
One of the things that Chris
talked about here is, again,
implementing least privileged policy.
So if ever you're writing a
policy in your AWS account
and there is a star there
in your policy document,
it should give you pause and think,
should I really be doing this?
Now that said, there are some
policies that do require star.
And so in that scenario,
sure that is okay,
but if you're gonna be accessing
a particular Dynamo table
or a particular S3 bucket,
you want to be as
explicit in the resource,
and you wanna be as explicit
in the particular actions
that you're allowing in that policy.
So again, least privileged policies.
Defense in depth, so we get...
Chris talked through a
lot of different ideas
in how you can actually secure
your serverless applications.
The idea here being don't just
apply one or two of these,
apply as many as possible.
So you're gonna use, you
know, IAM execution rules,
you're gonna use your
resource-based policies,
you're gonna use WAF to
protect your public endpoints.
You're gonna use SEPs to make sure
that developers aren't deploying
resources that don't comply
with organizational policies.
So there's a lot of different mechanisms
that you as an organization
can apply to ensure
that you have a secure
serverless application deployed.
Leverage the deep integrations across AWS,
and so one of the beautiful things
around building serverless applications,
whether these are synchronous APIs
or what we didn't spend a lot of time on
is like async event driven patterns.
The fact that AWS will
manage those integrations
on your behalf, and a lot of
times you're gonna configure
IAM roles or resource-based policies,
create those least privileged policies,
and let AWS do a lot of those
integrations on your behalf.
This helps kind of ease the burden
of a lot of the
undifferentiated heavy lifting
of configuring these
different integrations.
And last, you know,
automate these security
protection mechanisms, right?
So again, Chris talked
about things like GuardDuty,
so you can configure it so that
you get runtime protection.
In your CICD pipelines as
Chris talked about before,
you can implement a bunch
of these protections,
whether you're on the developer machine,
whether you're committing
code to a repository,
and triggering your CI actions
or even as you're deploying
into your environments,
you wanna make sure
that all of these checks
are being included as part
of that deployment process.
Okay, so I think that concludes.
We have a number of other
sessions that we wanna recommend
that you go take a look at.
These are a bunch that are really relevant
for as you're thinking about building,
and securing your serverless applications.
There are a number of other resources
that are available to you.
So these are some resources
that we recommend you go check out.
And with that we wanna
say thank you for coming.